خراب
والدمار
وهؤلاء الخصوم والاعداء قد يطلقون
صاروخا
او او ايضا الحرب البرانيه والتي تهدف الى
تدمير شبكاتنا
و تتسبب في دمار اقتصادي وكارثه اقتصاديه
العام الماضي حوالي ثلث الشركات
البريطانيه تعرضت لهجمات سيبرانيه
الكترونيه
وهذا ما ادى الى خسائر بالمليارات في
الصاد البريطاني نحن نعرف ان معظم تلك
الهجمات البرانيه مصدرها روسيا والصين وي
هتان الدولتان
تصمم قدرات فضائيه يمكن ان تحرمنا من
استغلال الفضاء وحتى حركات الهجره واسعه
النطاق يمكن ان تستخدم كسلاح حرب كما خبرت
ذلك بولندا والنرويج وغيرها من الدول في
معنى اخر وبكلمه
اخرى والجماعات من غير الدول وغيرها التي
تتعاون في ما بينها هذه يمكن ان تشكل
مشاكل وقلاقل اكبر بالنسبه للعالم وخلال
العقد الماضي هذه الحكومه حققت خطوات
مميزه فيما يتعلق بتعزيز قدراتنا الدفاعيه
ان تجديد عمليه المراجعه المتكامله وكذلك
الورقه الدفاعيه تضمن ان المملكه المتحده
ستتمكن من الدفاع عن نفسها في ظل هذه
الحروب الخطيره وقمنا بزياده الانفاقات
الدفاعيه والعسكريه بالمليارات وهذا ما
ساعد على تطوير قدراتنا
ومنها مثلا القدرات من الاجيال القادمه
بما في
ذلك حاملات الطائرات طائرات الاف 35 غيرها
كذلك
تدريب تدريب قواتنا وجنودنا حتى على
التعامل مع الحروب البرانيه ونحن كنا على
مستوى الحدث وارتقي الى مستوى
الحدث قدمنا دعما لا حدود له لاوكرانيا
وعززنا جهودهم وذلك من خلال حزمه حزم
مساعدات اخرها كان ما اعلنا عنه الاسبوع
الماضي وفيما يتعلق بحرب ضد تنظيم الدوله
وكنا في طليعه الاستجابه الدوليه والرد
الدولي حيث حافظنا على
الاستقرار الاستقرار الاقليمي حتى بعد
احداث السابع من اكتوبر حيث قمنا بارسال
مساعدات
انسانيه حتى
لغزه ونحن نتولى موضع الرياده او دورا
رياديا في الساحه الدوليه اضافه الى ذلك
فاننا قمنا بتعزيز دوري ومكانه المملكه
المتحده في العالم من منطقه المحيطين
الهاده حاده والهندي وكذلك منطقه الخليج
وغيرها
وكذلك استخدمنا قمه قمه القمه الدفاعيه في
عام 2000 24 وذلك من اجل وكذلك تعهدنا
بانفاق ما يزيد عن 2% من ناتج المحلي
الاجمالي على الجوانب الدفاعيه وللمره
الاولى بلدنا ينفق اكثر من 15 مليار دولار
على الجوانب الدفاعيه وهذا اكبر مبلغ
اتحدث عن 50 مليار دولار واتخذنا قرارات
مهمه وحرجه فيما يتعلق بالوصول الى تخصيص
2 وونص بال من نتج المحلي الاجمالي
للغايات الدفاعيه والعسكريه ومع تنام هذا
الاقتصاد فاننا ماضون في تحقيق ذلك الهدف
في اسرع وقت ممكن ولكن ان الاوان لكل
الحلفاء والدوله الديمقراطيه في كل انحاء
العالم لان تحذو حذونا
وتضمن بان انفاقات الدفاعيه تزداد وكما
ذكرت فان حقبه السلام وحلول السلام قد
انتهت قد خلال سنوات القادمه قد تتعامل مع
عدد خصوم واعداء مثل روسيا وكوريا
الشماليه والصين وايران وغيرها ولو سال
انفسنا ونحن نتامل في هذه الصراعات
المندلع في كل انحاء
العالم ربما نتساءل في ماذا كان تلك
الصراعات والنزاعات قد زادت او نقصت
واعتقد ان الاجابه بديهيه فقد زادت زياده
كبيره ولذلك فان عام 2024 يجب ان يمثل
نقطه
تحول كرانيه يجب ان يتحدد فيها مصير ذلك
البلد وبالنسبه للعالم هذه هذا العالم
الاكثر ديمقراطيه في
العالم في نصف سكان العالم في انتخابات
ديمقراطيه ونحن علينا ان نقرر مستقبل
دفاعاتنا الوطنيه الخيار صارخ وواضح تماما
البعض وخصوصا من اليسار لديهم ميل
ل تقليل من دور بريطانيا يقولون ان
بريطانيا لا تملك القوه ولا القوه ولا
القدره لان تكون بلدا مؤثرا على الساحه
العالميه وانا ولكنني اعتقد وبكل شغف
بان بان التقلي من
شان ان الذين يقللون من شان المملكه
المتحده و يستهينون بقدراتها هم مخطئون
وبالتالي علينا ان نتبنى خيارا
مختلفا تاريخ
جزيرتنا
يواجه تحديا نحن لطالما
حققنا انجازات في احلك الظروف ونحن نحقق
اكبر الانجازات عندما نتعرض للتهديد
وعندما تكون الخيارات الرهانات صعبه
ولكننا الان نعيش حقبه جديده وعلينا ان
نكون مستعدين لردع اعدائنا
ونقود حلفائنا وندافع عن
بلدنا وفيما يتعلق بالقدرات الردع فان
المملكه المتحده
حققت ميزه وا افضليه استراتيجيه على
خصومنا وتركيزنا على ال منظومه
النوويه
وكذلك نحن ماضو في توفير الحمايه من خلال
تعزيز قدراتنا الردع وبالتالي فاننا عزم
على انفاق 31 مليار دولار من اجل انتاج
غواصات حديثه تواكب القرن الحادي والر وفي
خضم هذا العالم الذي تشهده القلاقل
والنزاعات علينا ان نعمل على تحديث قواتنا
وقدراتنا ونجع ذلك ركيزه اساسيه كذلك نتخذ
القرارات المهمه وال المتعلقه بتحويل
قواتنا المسلحه وجيشنا
ليكون قادرا على ردع اي هجمات او تهديدات
تستهدف هنا كذلك ينبغي ان نمكن قواتنا
المسلحه من اجل تحقيق الاهداف التي نتطلع
الى تحقيقها وباشكال مختلفه ان نجاحات
الكبيره تم بنتها الاسبوع الماضي عن عندما
تمكنت المملكه المتحده من اتخاذ اجراءات
للدفاع عن نفسها ضد الحوثيين وكذلك زياده
دعمنا لاوكرانيا بارقام قياسيه
جديده اذا كان يعتقد بوتن بان ما احداث
الشرق الاوسط ستشتد تركيزنا هو واهم وان
اماله لن
تتحقق علينا ان
نواصل تمتين
وتوطيد تحالفاتنا كي يعرف العالم
باننا اقوياء و
بتحالفات سنكون
اقوى ونحن حريصون على دعم حلفائنا ولهذا
السبب فان المملكه
المتحده كانت شريكا مرغوبا به من قبل كثير
من الدول ومن ضمن الشراكات يبقى
حلف نيتو او حلف شمال الاطلسي في رياده
تلك التحالفات وحلف النيتو الان اصبح اكبر
من اي وقت مضى ولكن التحديات كبيره وكبيره
جدا ولهذا السبب فان المملكه المتحده
التزمت
بتوفير كامل قدراتنا البحريه والجويه
والبريه لخدمه النيتو ولكن في عام 2024
انا عازما على قيامي
ب بالمزيد ونحن سنرسل 20 الف عنصر ليقود
واحده من اكبر عمليات انتشار قوات تابعه
للحلف منذ نهايه الحرب البارده والذين
سيشاركون في تمرين او تدريب ستت فاست
ديفندر او المدافعون عن
الصبر وستشارك فيها كل دول الحلف بما في
ذلك السوي السويد لتقديم للتاكيد اننا
لن
باننا
سنبقى وحمله الطائرات اليزابيث ستحمل على
متنها طائرات مقاتل اف 35 اضافه الى
مدمرات
و كذلك غواصات التي
ستشارك في عمليات الاستطلاع
والمراقبه واكثر من
400 400 عنصر من قوات المشات البحريه
سيشاركون في مناورات في منطقه في
منطقه القطب الشمالي في اكثر اقصى الظروف
واشدها كذلك سيكون
هنالك فرقه فرقه
مشات
و كل ذلك يجعل عمليه الانتشار هي الاكبر
على صعيد القوات
البريه منذ 40 عاما ولكن حلف النيتو هو
جزء من شركاتنا الثريه والغنيه وحكومتنا
اتخذت جراش قرارات جريئه وذلك من اجل
تعزيز تحالفاتنا للدفاع عن انفسنا ضد
تهديدات عالميه
ونحن قمنا بتعزيز ما يسمى بشراكه الاوكس
والتي تضم استراليا والولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده وكذلك نشارك في شركات مع
ايطاليا
وكوريا الجنوبيه ونعمل على تطوير قدراتنا
الدفاعيه ونحن نهدف الى تحقيق افضليه
وميزه استراتيجيه حتى تكون لدينا حتى
تكون حتى تكون لنا اليد العليا
و لنعمل على الحفاظ على امن واستقرار
والسلام في المنطقه وهذا سيحدد الطريقه
واليه عملنا في المستقبل ولكن
من غير الكافي ان نعزز قدراتنا الدفاعيه
بل علينا ان نتولى دورا رياديا ندافع فيه
عن قيمنا وحاله اوكرانيا حاله اختبار
بالنسبه الينا ومستقبل اوكراني يمكن ان
يتحدد هذا العام المقاتلون الاوكراني
الشجعان نجحوا نجاحا منقطع النظير في دحر
القوات الروسيه و استعادوا اكثر من 50% من
الاراضي التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا وفتحوا ممر مائيا يطل على
البحر الاسود ولكن الدول الغربيه ينبغي ان
لا تخذلهم ولا تتخلى عنهم القياده
البريطانيه قامت بتحشيد القدرات وكان لذلك
تاثير مكننا من تحشيد اكثر من 50 بلدا
يشارك في دعم اوكرانيا ونحن نعمل على
تدريب اكثر من 60 الف عنصر او جنديا
اوكراني منذ شن روسيا هجومها على اوكرانيا
في عام 2014 واعلن عن تحالف بحري مع
النرويج وذلك من اجل الدفاع عن جناح
اوكرانيا البحري واكثر من 20 دوله انضمت
الى ذلك
التحالف والاسره الدوليه لا يمكن ان
تتراخى في دعمها لاوكرانيا فبوتي يعتقد
بان الغرب
يفتقر الى العزيم والاصرار للبقاء في
الرياده ولكننا اثبتنا خطا بوتن
و اي انتصار لبوتين سيؤدي الى زياده
التصعيد في المنطقه ذلك لانه يهدف الى
بناء الامبراطوريه الروسيه وهذا من شانه
ان يرسل رساله الى الجهات الاخرى بان
الدول الغربيه هي ضعيفه ويسه
وسهله المنال وعلى هذا الاساس فان المملكه
المتحده وقعت اتفاقيه
تاريخيه بين اوكرانيا وقعت اتفاقيه دفاع
مشترك بين اوكرانيا و وال المملكه
المتحده ونحن وقد زدنا دعمنا لاوكرانيا
ليصل مقدار الدعم والمساعدات الى سب
مليارات جنيه
استرليني اضافه الى المعدات والاسلحه التي
قدمناها 200 مليون جنيه سليني سيخصص
لتصنيع طائرات مسيره حديثه
ومتطوره وهذا ضمن سجيل
بريطانيا الذي نفخر به من حيث تزويد
اوكرانيا بما تحتاج اليه بريطانيا كانت
الدوله الاولى التي زودت اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه كذلك صواريخ مضاده للدروع
وصواريخ طويله بعيده المدى والان سنصبح
اكبر دوله تزود اوكرانيا بطائرات المسيره
وهذه الطائرات يتم تصنيعها وانتاجها في
بريطانيا بالتشارك مع حلفاء فنا وشاركنا
وذلك من اجل زياده قدرات اوكرانيا من حيث
الطائرات طائرات الدرون وهذه الاتفاقيات
الجديده مع
اوكرانيا تضع دعمنا في سياق رسمي على صعيد
الجوانب
الاستخباريه والتدريب
والدعم
الطبي
ونسعى لشركه قويه تمتد على بدا قرن كامل
ان الحرب في اوكرانيا هي معركه وجوديه
والحرب
وجوديه وتثبت انه ليس هنالك نزاعات منفصله
ومعزوله وهذا ونحن علينا ان نتصرف وفقا
للنظام القائم على المبادل نتصرف على نحو
عالمي
و نعمل ما شركان من اجل ضمان
سياده احدى الدول جيان كذلك سنكون ركيزه
اساسيه في العمليات الدوليه التي تهدف الى
حمايه حريه الملاحه في البحر الاحمر وخليج
عدن 15 بال من حركه التجاره العالميه تمر
عبر هذا الممر المائي الضيق ولكن الحوثيين
انتهكوا وبشكل مستمر القوانين وتحرشوا
بالسفن التجاريه في المنطقه وهددوها في
البحر الاحمر
راينا
فتصرفت بريطانيا من مبدا الدفاع عن النفس
ضد العدد المتنامي من الهجمات التي شنها
الحوثيون وبذلك ارسلنا رساله واضحه وجليه
لحليف الحوثيين ايران وارسلنا رساله واضحه
للبسه فيها بان يتوقفوا عن تهديد حياه
الناس وتهديد حركه الملاحه البحريه
وتحذيرات وانذارات كانت واضحه وهم اختاروا
ان يتجاهلوها الى ان وصل ان وصل سيل الزب
و انا والرئيس الامريكي وانا ورئيس
الوزراء قمنا
ب الموافقه على شن هجمات جويه باستخدام
طيرات التايفون وغيرها وقمنا بتوجيه ضربه
قاسمه
للحوثيين ومن خلال عملياتنا في البحر
الاحمر وزياده دعم لاوكرانيا هذا يبرهن
على ان بريطانيا ينبغي ان تكون في موضع
القياده في المستقبل وان تقدم دعما راسخ
لا يتزعزع ل حلفنا وان تت وان تعمل ضمن
تحالفات دوليه ر للرد على اي تهديدات
خبيثه وان نكون على مستوى الحدث عندما
يستدعي الامر الدفاع عن نفسنا لذلك الردع
والقياده يقودنا الى الركيزه الثالثه وهي
الاستعداد والوز للدفاع عن بلدنا اذا ما
اردنا ان ندافع عن بلدنا وعن وطننا علينا
ان نتاكد من ان منظومه الدفاع باكملها
متماسكه علينا ان نعمل على
جعلي علينا ان نكون دائما متقدمين على
خصومنا دائنا من حيث التصنيع
وغيرها نحن قدمنا للعالم الرادار
والمحركات النفاثه وغيرها ونحن
نمتلك شعله الابتكار والاختراع والمملكه
المتحده تمتلك اقتصادا تكنولوجيا يزيد
حجمه على ترليون دولار
امريكي واذا ما قمنا باستغلال هذه القدرات
من الابتكار والاختراع وغيرها لتعزيز
قدراتنا
الدفاعيه هذا يمكننا من وفير اسلحه مميزه
لجنودنا من الرجال
والنساء جنودنا الذين يدافعون عن الجناح
الشرقي لاوكرانيا ضد هجوم بوتين و قواتنا
البحريه والقيادات
البحريه التي من دونها لم نتمكن لن نتمكن
من الدفاع عن نفسنا واقول لهم جميعا
بانكم
ربما لا
تعرفون
من يدافعون عن بلدنا وهم الحجر
الاساس ولهم نقدم كامل الشكر والامتنان
والتقدير ولذلك التزام تجاه توفير ما
يحتاج اليه جنودنا
هو امر اساسي من خلال تخصيص الموارد
لهؤلاء الرجال والنساء الذين يبذلون
الغالي والرخيص من اجل الدفاع عن بلدنا
ولكن من اجل الدفاع عن بلدنا ضد تهديدات
المستقبل فانه ينبغي ان يتوفر لهم ما
يحتاجون اليه للقيام بمهامهم وواجباتهم